so
uh as i talk to you this afternoon
i
want you to think about something that
you're passionate about
and that you're willing to share with
other people that's unrelated to
programming
here's my example
i'm brian brennan and i'm really
passionate about music
in fact alex kind of embarrassed me
because that last track was my band
uh
over the past 10 years i've learned that
playing music is is something that's
really important to my well-being
i play in two bands and all my free time
that's not dedicated to programming and
community building i dedicate to
practicing and playing gigs
so i want to tell you a story about my
first js conf
i it was 2011 it was portland
i showed up i was traveling alone i had
just started mozilla and i didn't really
know anyone so i was just going by
myself
and i was really shy and i was anxious
um because i was just super intimidated
by all the awesome people
that were there like i there were people
that i followed on twitter there were
people whose like videos i had seen
giving talks at previous js comps
and i was i was just super intimidating
uh it was intimidating for me
because i didn't know how i was going to
fit in
i hadn't thought of myself as having
done anything particularly noteworthy
noteworthy
um so i just didn't know i didn't know
if i really belonged
so i was walking around the edge of the
room
trying to be invisible and paul iris
spotted me
and somehow recognized me from the
internet and he introduced himself and
invited me into his conversation
and i was just i just felt very welcome
and i asked paul if i could share that
just really small tiny story and he
barely remembered it
because for him it wasn't a big deal at
all
but for me it was such an act of warmth
and kindness at a time when i needed it
it made me feel welcome when i was
anxious about having a place to fit in
warmth and kindness matters
that's one of the reasons i wanted to
share that story small actions matter
in the right context
even the smallest kindness can be deeply
meaningful to someone in ways that are
unpredictable
paul didn't know i was going to be
telling that story here i asked him like
a week ago it was just for him to throw
away action but for me something that
really stuck with me
um also congratulations on your wedding
paul wherever you are
um
the other reason i wanted to share that
is because
i want us to start thinking about how we
welcome people into our communities
a lot of people approach communities in
the same way that i walked into that
conference shy and worried about fitting
in and
anxious most new people go in and they
try to stay invisible they follow us on
twitter they join our mailing list
they hang out in irc channels but they
don't interact with us and we have a
word for that it's called lurking
and it's a great strategy i've lurked on
the edges of all of the communities that
i've joined before deciding that that's
a place where i could see myself fitting
in
and i think we all have a job to convert
these lurkers into contributors
eventually we hope that we can turn them
into contributors collaborators and
possibly even friends
and to do that we need to remember to be
patient and kind
when the lurkers of our community the
people standing around the outside try
to make that first step
we were all novices once
and we need to remember
what it was like when we were new and
when we needed help
and that can be an incredibly hard thing
to do
because when you think about the same
thing all the time on a regular basis
when you're so entrenched in your own
community it can be really easy to
forget that people aren't also thinking
about that same thing all the time
something a colleague of mine selena
declan once said is
the best thing we can do as experts in
our field
is make it safer for novices to
experiment
and i think this is absolutely true
and more of us should spend time on that
if you want to get better at this i
recommend that you volunteer your time
as a teacher or mentor and preferably do
it in person
because guiding someone through learning
face to face helps you remember that you
are dealing with a real person
with their own unique background
rather than some abstract online
identity that's in need of your time and
energy
other people are people too
and that's another thing we need to get
better at
recognizing that other people are people
too even online we are all individual
human beings with our own individual
needs and values and feelings
and we need to respect that
last year there was a post on the linux
kernel developer mailing list
where linus tears into another developer
tells him to shut the up in all
caps and then rips him apart for the way
he handled some situation
and some of the developer response i saw
that really bummed me out
i saw people saying you need to have
thicker skin if you want to be a
programmer or shouldn't get in
development if you want to be coddled
and that's some really defeatist
language it's saying we have a culture
of abuse that tears people down
and it's your job to change and get used
to that rather than our responsibility
to start treating people better
i commend shara sharp who's a developer
on the colonel
and she put herself out there saying
that they really shouldn't stand for
that abuse in their community
and linus replied to sarah and his
response left me even more despondent
than the original post and i want to
read part of it to you i do it partly
because it's who i am and partly because
honestly i despise being subtle or nice
i simply don't believe in being polite
or politically correct
political correctness
i want to say a quick word about that
before i move on
i see that term thrown a lot around in
arguments on the internet and every time
i see it brought up it's by the people
who are resisting change
and it's used as a way to shut down
conversations by appealing to people's
fears
people hear politically correct
and they think that all the life of
their culture will be extinguished
if that's the path we go down that's why
people throw it into arguments they want
other people to back them up and say oh
no we can't go down that slippery slope
i'm not going to start wearing a tie to
work
so when you see this come up in an
argument i want you to remember it's a
loaded term and that you should rarely
take it at face value that doesn't mean
you have to reject everything the person
is saying but it means you should think
about it
just
realize that political correctness is is
not
it's a loaded term
anyway being nice is not about being
politically correct at all
being nice is about respecting another
human being
as an individual with their own feelings
needs and
values last year i saw isaac schluter
give a talk called building
compassionate communities in tech
uh it's excellent you should absolutely
watch it online
um you can just go type building
compassionate communities to ask jeeves
and you'll find it it's the first result
and in in his talk he recommends this
book called non-violent communication
and after he recommended that i read it
and i was actually really excited to see
and jen turner's talk
uh two days ago lessons in emotional
safety she also recommended that book so
this is the third time
so read it
uh but i wanna i wanna read you a quote
from that book that has stuck with me
we all pay dearly when people respond to
our values and needs
not out of a desire to give from the
heart but out of fear
guilt or shame
sooner or later we will experience the
consequences of diminished goodwill
on the part of those who comply with our
values out of a sense of either external
or internal coercion
they too pay emotionally
for they are likely to feel resentment
and decrease
self-esteem when they respond to us out
of fear guilt or shame
furthermore
each time others associate us in their
minds with any of those feelings
the likelihood of their responding
compassionately to our needs and values
in the future decreases
using guilt and public embarrassment and
fear to motivate people
may get things done in the short term
but it comes at a huge human cost
and this is not me saying you can't give
criticism we need criticism as software
developers that's how we build better
software
being nice means realizing that you are
dealing with another human being and
that how you give that criticism matters
we have
a stereotype as programmers
that were unemotional and cold and that
we operate on pure logic
and the stereotype is destroying us
we are human beings we have emotions and
we feel it when we're on the receiving
end of negativity
but so many of us have internalized an
unrealistic standard of how we're
supposed to be
so we avoid talking about it we don't
talk about how we feel we don't talk
about our emotions
we learn to
ignore them
and we learn to bottle them up
and then we wonder why so many of us
burn out
i
i want to tell a story that's going to
seem unrelated but i'm going to bring it
back around so just hang with me
i'm hispanic
and most of my life i've struggled with
my racial identity
my mother is from panama that's a small
country in central america for those of
you who are unaware
we have a canal
so my mother moved here when she was 18
a few later a few years later she had me
and my mom knew that the trouble uh that
english as a second language students
get into in early developmental
education
especially where i was growing up and
when i was growing up
um i've actually heard stories of of
some personal friends who are english as
a second language students and they were
held back because their teachers thought
they were mentally because they
couldn't speak english
and so my mother made the decision to
raise us in an english-only speaking
household so i never learned to speak
spanish
and that turned out to be a big deal for
me because the other hispanic kids all
spoke spanish
and i didn't fit in with them and they
held it against me because i couldn't
speak spanish
they made me are
i i was i i made myself feel like i
didn't have the right to call myself a
real hispanic
um years later i'm living with a guy
who's a friend of a friend
and he would sometimes start complaining
about hispanic people
not to other people like to me to my
face
uh
i i didn't mention this before but he
also collected guns
and
i was quite intimidated but after a
couple of times i i get up the courage
to say to him dude you know i'm hispanic
right
and he goes like without missing a beat
he's like oh well no no you're not
really hispanic you're different
i was different
i didn't fit into his mental model his
stereotype of what a hispanic person was
so i couldn't possibly be one
and the worst part is that at the time i
thought he was right
when he said that to me
it brought up all of my issues
about how i thought about myself
and i thought yeah maybe he's right
maybe i'm not a real hispanic
real programmer
how many times have you guys heard that
term
thank you
uh i run a user group in new york with
my pal judge smith called brooklyn.js
we use the js code of conduct and we
talk about it every meeting
we created brooklyn.js because we want a
safe place for people to come and learn
from each other but more importantly
to meet each other
and see each other as real human beings
a couple of meetups ago a guy went up to
one of our attendees a woman who's also
a good friend of mine and said you can't
be a real programmer you're too hot
this guy didn't even realize
that he went up to someone and said the
equivalent of up you don't look like how
i think you should so you don't belong
i was so so mad
and ashamed that this happened at my
meet up
and i'm still trying to think of ways
just beyond the code of conduct to make
sure this doesn't happen again
but in the meantime i want all of you to
do something for me
think really hard
and try to make all of your all of your
unconscious stereotypes that you might
have about programmers conscious think
about them
what we look like the types of things
we're supposed to be interested in
how we're supposed to think and feel
i want you to think about those things
and i want you to remind yourself that
all those things are
i want you to remember that we are all
different and the one guaranteed thing
we have in common is that we write
software and that's it
other than that we're all individuals
with our own identities our own needs
and our own values
it's our responsibility
as members of the community and leaders
of the community and members of various
communities
to build and maintain a culture
where it's safe to express our different
needs and values
where it's safe to just exist without
emotional or physical fear
think about the people lurking on the
edges
and what kind of example you want to set
for them
think about the effects your words have
on other people
brawl gave a powerful talk at jscoffee u
last year called people first and many
of the things that he said in that talk
has have stuck with me but i want to
share one particular quote
no matter your title
it is your job to make the people around
you feel cared about
empowered
encouraged
and humanized
as much as the internet connects us is
incredibly dehumanizing
we need to recognize and embrace our
responsibility for taking care of each
other
we need to recognize and acknowledge the
positive influence we have on each
other's lives
it shouldn't need to be a special
occasion to let a friend know how much
they mean to you
if you see someone who's under attack
stand up for them and if you see someone
who's hurting reach out to them
and if you yourself are hurting
talk to someone
don't ignore it
about eight years ago
i lived through my worst period of
depression
i was in college at the time and i
stopped going to class i failed out of
school i stopped going to work i dropped
all of my hobbies my computer broke and
i didn't even care i didn't bother to
get it fixed
i don't know what other people's
depression looks like but for me it's a
profound deep emptiness
but i never talked about it with anyone
i didn't want to burden people and
frankly i was ashamed with myself
how couldn't i control this
i don't have a lot of memories from that
period but i do remember the day i
decided to get help
i was driving on a freeway and a car was
coming in the opposite direction and as
it was about to pass me i had a thought
that almost turned into an action
i could swerve into this car right now
and it wouldn't matter
and it was a thought so strong i could
feel it in my hands physically that i
really wanted to do it
and at the last moment i didn't
i thought about what i'd almost done and
i thought about my mom and i thought
about my brother and i pulled over and i
started crying
and it took that moment and coming that
close for me to realize that i couldn't
handle it on my own and this is
something that i couldn't change in
myself or by myself
and i know that story makes a lot of you
feel awkward so i apologize if it's any
consolation i'm pretty sure i feel more
awkward about it so
uh
but if i was talking to you about
breaking my wrist or getting malaria
that would have been an easy story to
tell
but we have a social stigma around
mental health so it's not something we
talk about and so so many of us suffer
quietly and alone
a shame that we have this problem in
ourselves that we can't fix
and i think it might be worse for
programmers because not only do we have
that additional stereotype of being
unemotional
but because we are supposed to be able
to fix things it's kind of what we
do we need to take care of each other
let people know that you're there for
them
so when i was uh telling some of my
friends i was gonna give this talk
the most common advice was oh just be
funny just use a lot of animated gifs so
i'm pretty sure i nailed it
but for real i i know this has been some
sustained real talk and i want to thank
you for giving me your attention
i actually feel incredibly positive
about our future more than i have in the
past um
i see us starting to have open hard
conversations about a lot of this stuff
where we wouldn't have dared to talk
about it before
i see more people starting to recognize
that there is humanity behind what we do
and seeing that we need to learn how to
deal with that just as much as we need
to learn how to deal with anything else
in our field
i've met and i continue to meet so many
awesome people through programming and
made friendships that even if i quit
programming tomorrow i'd want to
maintain
in the beginning i asked you to think
about some of the things you're
passionate about that aren't programming
and as we wrap this up and go into our
last evening of celebration
i want you to remember those things and
when you talk to each other
don't just talk about what you do or
where you work bring your entire self to
the conversation
you are so much more than just your
opinion on ember promises
remember that being awesome to each
other starts with being awesome to
ourselves
thank you very much i love you all
you